hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves in
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet and so to help
you on your journey we're continuing the
top five book series where we basically
look at five books that are trending on
Amazon in a certain category and
thinking might be of interesting value
to you guys
entrepreneurs kind of build your
business and so today we're looking at
the top five books for small business
owners coming in at number five is the
hard thing about hard things by Ben
Horowitz Ben Horowitz you originally
referred to as the CEO Whisperer is your
new book the hard thing about hard
things a way to stop whispering and get
the word out more widely yeah I'm going
to step my game up to the CEO shatter
but actually the reason I wrote the book
was when I was CEO I would have these
times where I'd be up at two o'clock in
the morning and in a cold sweat and
trying to figure out why then the
management books that I read were
helping me you know I was just stuck and
what I came to realize was most of the
books that I had read were about here
are all the things that you do to not
screw up your company but once your
company is screwed up you're on your own
and it turns out that the like the
really hard part about running a company
is when things go go wrong or when you
get a very emotionally difficult
situation and there wasn't anything for
that so that's kind of what prompted me
to write the book coming in at number
four is girlboss by Sophia Amoruso
[Music]
did you ever think that it would be such
a phenomenon no I mean I think everybody
wants their books to be a best-seller
and so it wasn't something that we you
know that we didn't talk about but I
didn't see no I've never written a book
before I don't know how the whole world
work he's very new to me and yeah it was
just kind of like it's an easy book to
read on the Sunday it's not super heavy
but it's entertaining it's not like if
you do these five things this will
happen to you a lot of storytelling an
anecdote
some fun quotes what's your favorite
story and here was heard go to oh god I
mean I think you know a lot of people
ask when was the moment that was kind of
like a turning point for you and for me
it was a really crazy time I was on eBay
and went to a thrift store was just
looking around and found a Chanel jacket
for $8.00 and you know had no idea how
much it was worth I was like wow she now
eight dollars call me buy it put it on
eBay for $9.99 it could have sold for
$9.99 but of course people bid on it in
auction and after a week it would for
like over a thousand dollars just like
yeah just such a cool vote of confidence
that something was working coming in
number three issue dog by phil night
[Music]
other people have written books about
nike this is your first time my take us
back you're out of school you and your
dad so you've got this crazy idea that's
what you kept saying this crazy idea
right how did that happen well basically
it was generated from two places
basically the running track at Oregon
where environment was always fill in the
shoes and then at Stanford Business
School I took an entrepreneurship class
where I wrote about you know the track
shoe industry and how to break into it
and so the two ideas kept growing and
then finally I went to my father and
said I need to pursue this a bit was
there ever a time that you thought this
isn't and we wouldn't read the book I
mean even though I know the outcome the
times I'm reading it and saying he's not
going to make it he's not going to all
absolutely right on the edge a couple
times that I know I say was every time
yeah there were sometimes the most scary
was when he got kicked out of the bank
for the second time and they told me
that they turned me in to the FBI and I
don't know
these are little tough times that they
can't take the house but no but I did
say if we failed I was going to try it
again because I was enjoying it so much
and what do you say to because we've had
a lot of young people that are starting
their businesses and there are a lot of
people who watch and they have a passion
they have they want to have fun what do
you say to a young any entrepreneurs
well I think there's a couple things so
that if you're going to be an
entrepreneur you better be prepared for
long hours on a lot of dark moments and
I guess that's one thing that's shown in
the book and I think you know you really
have to have a passion about it and you
have to
have a reason to succeed you can't it
isn't to be just something that you want
to be that you have to have a niche and
a passion you need those two things
coming in at number two is Elon Musk by
Ashley Vance so in 2012 they did a
Businessweek cover story on Elon and you
know we got along pretty well I got to
spend a bunch of time with him going
through the SpaceX factory went to movie
premieres and all this stuff and and and
you know the companies were very
interesting in Elon was much more
interesting that I'd given him credit
for before the story he you know I'd
sort of pegged it was just like a
one-note techno utopian kind of guy and
you know he turned out to be this great
interview he didn't have PR handlers
around him so you could you had access
to him and he would answer just about
anything you asked him and so I decided
then this is a guy I really want to
write about and I'd been looking for a
book to do and so after I did the story
a couple months went by and I started to
feel Elan out about doing a book and I
and I think I either said I'm an email
or call them on the phone and I you know
I said this is what I want to do is I'd
look a bunch of people have asked me in
the past and I'm not gonna I'm not going
to do it look they're not going to help
you do the book and then I went to New
York and I sold the book anyway I
thought I would sort of forces here in a
little bit of that I arranged another
meeting with them and I'll never forget
it was on a Saturday at Tesla and I came
in I was like look I've sold the book
and he said I'm still not gonna
cooperate with you and so I spent like
18 months interviewing hundreds of
people I found like all these SpaceX and
pestle employees most of you had laughed
all the zip to PayPal people that he'd
worked with his ex-girlfriend's is like
childhood friends and and all that stuff
and then you know a lot of those people
would they would call back feel on and
say should I speak to him or not and he
was a pretty good sport about it there's
nobody that he told not to and so I
think that happened enough times
after about 18 months of doing it I was
at home it's like 6:30 at night on a
weekday and off of my caller ID it was a
LAN musk and I picked up the phone and
he said he said look I can basically
who's going to go one of two ways I
could shut down all these people that
call me and ask whether you know I
should let them talk to you or I could
cooperate with the book I was like
obviously you should choose option
number B the other option B and and then
we set up a meeting to to talk about he
wanted to he wanted to be able to he
wanted have some control over it
initially he wanted to be able to read
the book before it came out and then he
wanted to put footnotes in the book and
if you like know anything about Ilan
that would mean you know the footnotes
would be longer than the book and that
the book would probably never be
published and sure so I kind of push
back on him on that I had this huge
speech prepared and I got like five
minutes into it and he just said okay
Wow yeah to his credit after that he
gave me access to everybody I wanted and
then he agreed to have a meeting with me
you know once a month he said for his
life just took it ended up being about
eight months and we would have like
three four five hours dinners what is it
like to spend a few hours a month
interviewing you online it was really
fun I at the beginning of nerve-racking
because I I never knew how many of these
interviews I would actually get even
though he had agreed to it I was figured
sort of that you know he might do one
and then he'd be like okay that's it and
then and then I thought you know he
might get sick of it after a while and
just cut me off so each one it was sort
of like felt like an accomplishment you
know but then it was frustrating because
the first four I really didn't I was
getting lots of useful stuff but nothing
that was I could tell he was still
holding back a bit and he was repeating
a lot of stories that if you kind of
watch elon speeches and other talks that
you would have heard
for sure and so that was frustrating and
then I'm still not sure exactly what
happened but around the fourth meeting
we should always do the same thing we
would get their heats really late so
it'd be like 8:30 9 o'clock at night and
and we would go a few times until just
everybody had left and it was kind of
one of those things there's like hardly
anybody there and he just was like a
flip the switch kind of flipped he I
think he sort of really committed to
doing it and and he became much more
relaxed and easygoing and the number one
book for small business owners is the 7
Habits of Highly Effective People by
Stephen Covey Stephen Covey is here he
is one of the big bet fellows and one of
the Guru's in the world of personal
leadership taking control of your life
you spoke with President Clinton his
book the 7 Habits of Highly Effective
People is a big bestseller has been on
the bestseller list for a very long time
where did this book come from I mean
what makes the element of this below
essentially about twenty years of just
working with organizations and with
people and trying to find what are the
common denominators that represent true
success not just monetary success but a
balanced long-term as well as short-term
success and that literature review study
going back to 1776 was very significant
because I just learned that that the
popular culture must focus on principles
that do not change otherwise popular
culture is all based on a flawed
foundation and for the first hundred and
fifty years while we were on the farm
essentially it did its focused upon
fundamental principles like diligence
industry integrity honesty openness
service growth but then when we moved
from the farm into the Industrial Age it
became more abstracted from reality then
we move into the Information Age even
more abstracted till today we're in
heavy into techniques and technologies
and image building and it pulled away to
a great extent in my judgment from our
character roots so your call to your
audience is to come back to basic values
right come back restore the character
ethic in our culture and then we can
restore trust inside our institutions
otherwise we're always in a sense plain
on the surface and living for
appearances and but in the long run
particularly in today's global economy
you can't compete unless you have high
trust cultures to produce the kind of
quality that can compete the seven
Habits of Highly Effective People
beginning with number one to be
proactive you know be proactive
basically means take responsibility take
initiative you are not an animal don't
wait for it to happen to you see well
seize the moment don't be a victim don't
get your mind into the weaknesses of
other people like your spouse or your
boss or some institution accept the fact
that you have the power to choose your
response in any given set of
circumstances second is second begin
with the end in mind
get a clear sense of what your life is
about what your values are what you're
going to live by and what your sense of
mission is 100 if you're going to play
in the Super Bowl then the Cowboys
better have a mission and they better
know what they expect at the end of two
halves right and also they may have a
lot of short-term goals that would lead
toward that mission so that would be
beginning at the end and - the
intellectual creation where habit 3
putting first things first is the
physical creation in other words you do
it habit - says this is the blueprint
for my house habit 3 says now
constructed for think win-win mutual
benefit see in all not win lose not lose
win don't be a martyr
win win yeah I win you win right in all
situations
even if I have to advocate what is the
win for you because if you don't want to
win number five is seek first to
understand then to be understood is the
one you don't always get right into oh
yeah this is the basis of all
professionalism really to always
understand before you judge must the one
most people blow up but when I blow them
off rather stand before you before you
judge before you act before you seek to
be understood understand before you're
understood diagnose someone's eyes
before you prescribe glasses listen to
your child and the problem and be sure
you understand before you're rushing
with a quick solution think part of that
also is it before you even think about a
reply just think about understanding you
listen with the intent to understand not
with the intent to reply you can see why
that necessitates internal security that
comes from the first three habits
because otherwise you're at risk you
don't know what's going to happen you
have to be very genuinely open to listen
within their frame of reference rather
than to kind of politely listen and then
prepare your own response in fact
guidance down value that that's a
difficult one to number six number six
synergize which basically means create
together something that is better than
what I brought to the table or what you
brought to the table number seven
sharpen the saw is the renewal habit of
you know physically exercising mentally
sharpening the saw continue your
education spiritually recommit yourself
to your ultimate value system and to
live by your conscience see that
sharpening the saw so thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know have you read these books
any of them have they had an impact on
your business somehow are you planning
on reading some of them after watching
this video which ones and why leave your
thoughts down the comments below I'm
really curious to hear from you and
maybe this series will also continue
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love teasing